[Musica]
per fare le storie
occorrono almeno tre cose
serve un protagonista
serve un obiettivo e serve un ostacolo
una storia è il viaggio che il
protagonista deve intraprendere per
raggiungere o non raggiungere un
obiettivo questo vale sia per i minstro
vati su internet che domani ci saremo
dimenticati e sia per le grandi storie
del passato che ci raccontiamo ancora
dopo anni e anni da caino e abele fino a
rocky lo squalo guerre stellari
c'è tutta una tradizione di studiosi che
confrontando le grandi storie hanno
cercato di capire che cosa avessero in
comune hanno trovato una struttura
sottostante
c'è uno psicologo canadese jordan
peterson che sostenuto sostiene
addirittura che tutte le culture umane
sono edificate sulle fondamenta della
stessa grande storia che questo qui
paradiso
incontro con il caos
caduta e redenzione ora questo e
michelangelo sono le scene della
cappella sistina
questo è il cristo della minerva
ma la struttura in tre atti è molto più
antica del cristianesimo
il primo a parlarne aristotele e il
tutti i manuali di sceneggiatura sono
sostanzialmente delle elaborazioni del
suo modello
ci sono quattro atti in realtà sono solo
tre cioè quello in mezzo che il doppio
degli altri due e è diviso in 2a e 2b
praticamente per
[Musica]
spiegare come gli sceneggiatori
applicano questa questo modello per
scrivere le loro storie ne usata una che
mi ha abbastanza familiare perché quella
che mi ha portato qui
allora siamo a bologna agli inizi degli
anni 90 c'è uno studente che vuole
diventare autore e
[Musica]
ho cercato delle
foto d'epoca no però poi ho trovato
questa che che è un po più diciamo che
rende maggiormente l'idea di quello che
allora cioè questa un personaggio un po
tormentato e non è un caso perché
aristotele addirittura diceva che nel
primo atto delle storie
il protagonista deve esse deve fare un
pò pena sostanzialmente è questo
pensate tra l'altro a tutti quei
protagonisti di storie di successo come
che ne so peter parker look skywalker
harry potter sono un sacco di orfani
fanno pena
questo l'idea che sta sotto tutto questo
è che se noi stabiliamo una connessione
emotiva con il protagonista saremmo
portati a
seguirlo nel suo viaggio per quanto
incredibile verso l'obiettivo
l'obiettivo
eccolo qua
l'obiettivo è di questo personaggio di
questo studente è quello di fare
l'autore insomma è lui cioè io ci provo
facendo disegnando fumetti quindi
realizzo insomma una serie di storie
frequenta una scuola incontro colleghi
maestri
metto nei fumetti delle cose che di
solito nei fumetti non si vedono tanto
perché mi piace molto la pittura
rinascimentale i preraffaelliti e quindi
metto fanti ninfe cose che di solito nei
fumetti non si trovano tanto questa
invece è una una
tavola dove c'è robben che insomma
perlustra dei tetti della città poi a un
certo punto mette un piede in fallo
finisce una specie di bordello parigino
vabbè
l'ostacolo l'ostacolo in questo caso è
il fatto che a disegnare sono piuttosto
lento quindi
è successo un paio di volte che io
terminarsi una serie e alla fine
portandola nella rivista che me l'ha
commissionata scopro che è sparita dal
mercato è il momento in cui il manga
arrivano è in breve tempo somma
conquistano tutto
addirittura
questo succede varie volte tra cui
questa qui per esempio è una cosa che ho
pubblicato
18 anni dopo che è uscita il primo
capitolo in
rivista ciò è ovvio che non può andare
avanti così per cui
noi siamo alla fine del primo atto
questo è il momento nel quale il
protagonista dell'obiettivo che si
allontana e quindi deve fare
assolutamente qualcosa perché sennò
scapperà via è quindi il momento che noi
chiamiamo il primo punto di svolta in
cui si alza la posta in gioco e
soprattutto viene sollevata la domanda
fondamentale di ogni storia che cioè il
protagonista riuscirà a raggiungere
l'obiettivo
lo studente riuscirà a fare il
l'autore e quindi
io mi
mi trasferisco a da da bologna a roma e
con l'idea di abbandonare i fumetti e di
cercare di diventare autore di cinema di
tv
ora ci troviamo
agli inizi del 2000 il caos l'incontro
con il caos non è necessariamente un
male come il paradiso del primo atto in
questo caso non è assolutamente un male
tanto è vero che
in italia ci sono un sacco di soldi da
investire in tv c'è stato il millennium
bug ma nessuno insomma se l'è filato
io e mio fratello marco senza aver mai
fatto nulla e in televisione ci mettiamo
a pensare ci inventiamo questa sitcom
dove c'è il protagonista che fa il
ginecologo la portiamo down
da un produttore e lui ce l'ha compra
subito al primo colpo
ora non solo lui né entusiasma ma lui ci
manda a spese sue della società insomma
a los angeles a vedere come si fanno le
sit com americane per noi è un sogno non
arriviamo lì arriviamo all vediamo gli
studi della paramount conosciamo gli
attori e gli autori di fraser che allora
era la nostra sitcom preferita la nostra
proprio la nostra pietra di paragone e
sono quei momenti nella vita dove tutto
sembra fichissimo tutto sembra possibile
il protagonista è si sente invincibile e
l'obiettivo è proprio lì proprio a
portata di mano vanno messi tutti lì
alla fine del
all'inizio del secondo atto quindi
torniamo a casa
in italia e cerchiamo di finalmente di
produrla questo sito scopriamo che il
protagonista che era destinato a
interpretare il ginecologo non vuole
fare più il ginecologo dice voglio fare
l'entomologo
ok vabbè riscriviamo mezzo mondo poi
dopo un po le riprese finalmente
cominciano e lui finisce in coma
giuro cioè in coma e l'anno dopo quando
si è fortunatamente ripreso
finalmente siamo pronti ad annunciare
che questi da questa sitcom
meravigliosa questa questo fraser
italiano questo un
prodotto che è sofisticato che non c'è
tutte quelle battuti nelle solite
sciocchezze delle cose italiane che
soprattutto non a quelle smorfie
orribile chi fanno gli attori italiani
quando quando vogliono far ridere per
forza e questo è quello che ne è venuto
fuori
[Musica]
cioè fa ancora malissimo ancora
veramente male questa c'è questo
[Applauso]
se questo è il momento in cui il
protagonista vede che l'obiettivo si sta
allontanando e scopre che il viaggio
verso l'obiettivo è costellato di di
ostacoli molto più alti del previsto
quindi una cosa a inventarsi una serie
di successo una cosa e scriverla una
cosa poi realizzarla veramente quindi i
produttori
mecenati scompaiono io da questo momento
scrivo un po di tutto dalle soap opera
ai polizieschi ad altre sit com
melodrammi ma per quando tutto gli
impegni veramente a fare il meglio il
mio lavoro praticamente scopro che il la
prassi a quella di prendere le
sceneggiature di strapazzare fino a
pochissimi minuti prima di arrivare sul
set praticamente ci mettono le mani e
tutti i produttori
gli attori gli editor soprattutto i
registi che diventano una cosa che mi
sta i registi cioè quindi praticamente
la mentre quando faccio i fumetti quello
che è stampato è proprio lì è uguale a
quello che ho fatto io quando invece si
parla di televisione vedo il prodotto
finale la distanza è talmente alta
talmente ampia che comincia a pensare
che esiste proprio un complotto di
registi malvagi che si divertono a
distruggere le mie sceneggiature e tutto
questo mentre progetti ai quali sono più
affezionato invece non vanno per niente
importo questa è una storia d'amore tra
terra e lo spazio questo invece è una
origin story di un super eroe italiano
a un certo punto sto facendo questa
miniserie ambientata a napoli è una
commedia che parla di criminalità quindi
i protagonisti sono dei cantanti
neomelodici e dei boss di camorra si
chiama la famiglia gambardella esce in
tv ed è una storia d'amore che non
c'entra proprio niente
è la goccia che fa traboccare il vaso
allora qui siamo arrivati proprio al
punto centrale tra tra a metà del
secondo atto no qui si alza nuovamente
la posta in gioco l'obiettivo ormai si
sta allontanando se non vuole per
perderlo di vista il protagonista deve
fare qualche cosa in più deve rischiare
anche a costo di imboccare una via di
non ritorno quindi con il mio collega
nicola guaglianone che è diventato nel
frattempo il mio partner di scrittura
rilasciato questa intervista mucchio
selvaggio
in cui rispondiamo poi ironicamente però
in realtà pieni di livore sul perché la
fiction italiana fa è così brutta siamo
nel 2013 e la nostra risposta appunto un
po su questi su queste su questi toni
cioè gli sceneggiatori pensano che i
registi siano incapaci i registi pensano
che gli sceneggiatori siano analfabeti i
registi sceneggiatori pensano che gli
attori siano cani e nel frattempo i
produttori scappano con i soldi ora dal
punto di vista delle relazioni
professionali è una pessima idea il 2 b
è l'atto della caduta
quindi qui arrivano i cattivi cioè
l'obiettivo è ormai un puntino
lontanissimo l'italia è in crisi
finanziarie io non trovo più lavoro
grazie all altro che fare l'autore qui
si tratta di trovare i soldi per pagare
l'affitto quindi non trovando più niente
da fare mi capita di trovare una serie
di lavori sono sono delle pubblicità per
un grande ospedale romano di proprietà
del vaticano auto realmente non è niente
di che lavoro anche un casino però tutto
sommato insomma spero di rimettere a
posto le mie finanze
no perché
gli amministratori dell'ospedale cioè
oltre agli 800 milioni che si portano a
casa ci sono anche quelli delle mie
fatture quindi il praticello la
situazione precipita io mi cerco insomma
galleggiare con l'arte erotica per
amatori però insomma è solo una goccia
nel mare poi i soldi finiscono fino a
arrivare qui dove mi appresto a
realizzare una serie di falsi schifano
allora e mi fermo fortunatamente
all'ultimo secondo perché mi accorgo che
anche tra i falsari di schifano esiste
una competizione piuttosto
agguerrita quindi comunque insomma
attenzione qui siamo arrivati proprio a
quasi in fondo alla caduta e la caduta
deve essere particolarmente
particolarmente pesante il protagonista
deve essere veramente trattato male
quindi nel dubbio in questo punto della
storia non fare arrivare se no che ne so
suo fratello a dargli una mano grazie
marco
ma farlo magari invece andare
direttamente in ospedale
magari proprio al nel giorno successivo
di una separazione sentimentale
allora questo è un altro momento topico
delle sceneggiature noi lo chiamiamo la
buia notte dell'anima
lì il protagonista deve proprio toccare
il fondo prima di potersi rialzare
qui qualcosa di veramente molto di molto
importante per lui deve morire può
essere l'obiettivo oppure un mentore una
persona cara un amico l'amante perché
lui deve capire che se si trova in
questa situazione potrebbe non essere
solo un caso
e quindi siamo arrivati al terzo atto
dove li si può partire un nuovo punto di
svolta che può portare la storia è tutta
in un'altra direzione e può essere come
succede questo può essere come ho detto
prima sarà cioè può essere un
illuminazione improvvisano ci sono un
sacco di esempi di detective che vedono
un un indizio che prima invece avevano
avevano trascurato
oppure può essere proprio l'inizio
dell'ultima battaglia tipo rocchi che
scende che sale sul ring oppure il
gladiatore che scende che scende
nell'arena
[Musica]
in ogni caso può essere anche un evento
che abbiamo seminato già in precedenza e
che solo adesso
offre al protagonista una seconda chance
in questa storia è andata così
[Musica]
c'è una ragione che cresce in me
no
non so
marzia
dopo
cos'è successo che dopo un bel po di
porta in faccia anche lui gabriele
mainetti il regista è riuscito a
costituire la propria di casa di
produzione ha girato l'undicesima
stesura di lo chiamavano jeeg robot
il film esce nel 2015 nel 2016 ha un
buon successo quindi andiamo ai david da
cui poi è tutto molto molto più semplice
scrivo quindi altri altri film altre
serie
altri film e altre serie
fino ad arrivare qui
quindi siamo alla fine del terzo atto
siamo arrivati al climax di clean è il
momento nel quale finalmente la domanda
fondamentale di ogni storia riceve la
sua risposta quindi qui scopriamo se
rocchi è riuscita a rimanere in piedi
fino alla quindicesima ripresa se brody
è riuscito ad ammazzare lo squalo è
insomma scopriamo se la storia finisce
con un happy ending oppure insomma si è
trasformata in tragedia
ora per quello che mi riguarda la cose
non sono andate troppo male se sono qui
ovviamente perché faccio il mestiere che
desideravo fare
certo si sapeva pure prima ma il bello
delle storie non è semplicemente andare
a vedere come va a finire perché
altrimenti non ci guarderemo le serie
quando sappiamo perfettamente fin
dall'inizio che l'obiettivo che andiamo
a rincorrere per tutta una stagione
nell'ultima puntata verrà spostato nella
stagione successiva o verrà sostituito
con un obiettivo completamente nuovo
la verità è che nelle storie come in
tante altre cose in realtà il viaggio è
più importante della metà cioè il
protagonista
nel rincorrere l'obiettivo si rende
conto piano piano che i veri nemici non
hanno i guantoni da box di apollo creed
non hanno i denti aguzzi dello squalo
non hanno neanche la sedia da regista
dalla quale si divertono a rovinarti le
sceneggiature
no in realtà
il pupazzo rosa il pupazzo rosa quello
questo qui che questo è il protagonista
che nel frattempo si è ridotto in questi
termini cioè quello che gli complica la
vita non è un nemico esterno è una parte
di lui e si può si può chiamare in tanti
modi in sicurezza fiducia in se stessi
oppure anche il contrario no superbia
supponenza invidia gelosia
insomma la l'idea è che
l'idea che le grandi storie
ci raccontano ci dicono che cambiare è
possibile
e a noi sta a decidere che cosa fare
cioè la memoria non serve per ricordare
il passato serve per evitare di
commettere gli stessi errori in futuro e
forse per questo
dicevo che è per questo forse che
continuiamo a
ricordare a raccontare a scrivere le
grandi storie tutto questo